hey leute willkommen bei einer neuen
folge happy wales ich habe schon länger
nicht mehr aufgenommen weil ich
irgendwie nicht so die lust daran hatte
an diesem spiel doch dann habe ich mir
wieder ein paar videos von anderen
leuten angesehen dann habe ich mir
gedacht komm du spielst aber wieder okay
ich soll einfach mal in den bus levels
ordner gehen welche gesagt und dass
hierbei rating sortieren irgendwie wenn
das klappt aber bei mir eigentlich keine
ahnung hat man kann ich das nicht
irgendwie uploaded edita sword
buy-rating label charakter wir können
einfach diesen dieses welchen welcher
typ ist neu focus dikmen heißt er glaube
ich da können wir einfach gewonnen
sondern level spielen von hardware ihr
okay test area ich weiß gar nicht wie
geht das ja ja ich weiß genau wie es
geht lustig da ich springe robbe die wie
geht denn überhaupt ach so ach so huber
space ach so ach so das sind richtige
wende da muss jetzt erst mal darüber
kommen und salto oder geil
der chip kann sich ja nicht mehr dabei
weh tun und wir halten es gedrückt und
springer scheiße so spree auf rot ja
genauso so wie kann ein bisschen nein
nein da würde ich gar nicht so genau
genau da sehr schön sehr schön
sehr schön sehr schön sehr schön so dass
irgendwie ist ein dokument so kompakt so
machen wir ein bisschen weniger naja ok
noch weniger
das tut auch weh egal in titz nicht
wählen erst chuck norris hat dabei kann
das so falsch
egal wann ich glaube ich sollte mich da
vielleicht nicht so durchdrehen sondern
genauso auch da hinten schon das ziel
sehr schön ist das egal
ja aber so ist das seien 1 8 wieder
zurückgesprungen idiot so ich bin mir
nach hinten hier wieder durch springen
ja wissen nach hinten sehr schön direkt
in einem durch hier also was das sein
will muss das sein
wie kann das denn so cool jetzt habe ich
sogar eine bewertung abgeben das ist ja
cool
okay wir spielen wir noch ein bisschen
mit dem pogo stick kill them all töte
alle okay ich mache ich da die irgendwas
kann ich das irgendwie steuern oder so
control irgendwann irgendwo irgendwie
funktioniert gar nix hat sich irgendwie
ach das ist ein blödes da will ich mag
diese will nicht ich will einfach
irgendwo rum fahren
poco game das hört sich doch gut an aber
ich hatte ich schaff's nicht mehr hh
jeden fall schöner salto nochmal so
chastain nein ich glaube ich sollte mich
sollte erst mal aufladen und dann wenn
ich loslasse ja genau so meine ich das
setzt sich da erst mal hin sehr gut wir
müssen es dann auch irgendwann mal
hinkriegen jordan 11 uhr dann gleich
zwei auf einmal sehr schön sehr schön
we try bitte danke hopp oder topp 333
gewinnt egal wann so das ist gut ein
bisschen zurück springen da muss ich
eigentlich auf die dinger da drauf
springen
ich weiß es gar nicht ja das war schon
klar dass das nicht funktioniert und ob
nach egal so okay jetzt sind wir schon
bei gold angelangt nein nein nein
falsche taste falsche taste falsche
taste falsche taste falsche taste und
space gedrückt halten und hoch und
wieder runter so ist er nach hinten und
mein gott recording willst du ja ich
nehme es gerade auf weil ich ja auch so
gut bin einfach sehr schön
ok
wie schaffen wir auch noch vor der wahl
sehr schwer war sehr sauber so acht mal
aufgefallen auch wenn ich runter und
hoch gedrückt halte schaffe ich es
trotzdem rückwärts und hoch zu gehen
so also ich muss sich immer space drücke
nach fakten schaffen wir
und ja man du bist mein gott ich glaube
da kann man einfach vorher sehr schön
exotisch news hd hart die nation spendet
mir herzen oder irgendwie ja genauso
wenn wir schon direkt am anfang so hier
drauf ja genauso
ich hoffe das level nicht oder ich
probier's mal noch mal sagt er aber ich
soll dir ganz lange probieren damit auch
ja ganz langweilig wird in den letzten
top da war schon mal gut da war es
natürlich schlecht so extreme wenn ihr
weil das war ein blödes level
ich verstehe ich warum das eine gute
bewertung hat egal 99% posten
nein ich glaube man muss es irgendwie
dadurch schaffen
aber das kann ja gar nicht so schwer
sein
99 prozent unmöglich das heißt so
irgendwie 99 prozent der leute die das
spiel kriegen das nicht hin dann werde
ich diese eine prozent sein der das
hinkriegt nein ach das war schon mal nah
dran denn ich sagen die restlichen acht
minuten in diesem part beschäftigen uns
doch mal damit hier irgendwie
durchzukommen
ach mist aber auch knapp
nein nein erstmal ganz hoch ich glaube
wir müssen einfach noch ein stück weiter
nach hinten
nein ach mist komplett egal so kommt
jetzt wieder nach hinten
ach nee das war überhaupt komplett
falsch so und hoch um mein gott ich
möchte jetzt einfach mal nichts sagen
aber was könnte ich jetzt nicht ja das
war auf jeden fall die richtige
entscheidung
stück nach hinten einfach noch los ich
glaube das war wieder zu weit nach
hinten wir gehen wir einfach mal
hingehen
wir gehen einfach so hierhin und dann so
das müsste doch jetzt eigentlich immer
irgendwann machbar sein
so probiert es mal von hier
nein egal so so
na ja genau das war auf jeden fall
richtig und so nein egal
und zack ach ich hab keine lust mehr
wir schaffen das nicht so das letzte
level mit dem focus dikmen okay weil
kommt un tcl you charaktertest in
testing laboratory holt space to pay for
james not rated at bloggt mein gott wie
schwer
ja ich schaff ich irgendwie war das klar
so geschafft roxy testtour ok jump
island - das wird schwer glaub ich nein
so los geht's so bei den ersten block
darüber ja genauso ja genauso er rechne
ich versuchen wir hier irgendwie
rüberzukommen
ich glaube jetzt muss ich dann damit
landen nach genau auf seiner mine gab es
ja wohl nicht so und hier wird davor und
hobby brauche ich für diesen block immer
zwei so sehr schön sehr schön sehr schön
so weitergeht
ich will noch ein stück weiter nach
vorne das zum stück weiter nach vorne
man das kann doch nicht so schwer sein
und schon wieder braucht hierfür 23
korrigiere vielleicht sogar 44 und hobby
sie ja das war leicht der test ist
dennoch leicht aber diese landminen
hamann so muss das sein
quatchi teilte mit ihr poker stick okay
ich bin mir egal
ok
nein nein nein nein
egal wir haben den test auf jeden fall
geschafft
und weiter geht's sehr schön
aha ok will probieren ein anderes level
das ist jetzt wirklich das allerletzte
level mit dem posting raid5 you save
your place
[Musik]
okay das level weit ziemlich komisch
aber weigert nothing to improve weiß ich
nicht okay das war relativ kurz von
daher wird das jetzt einfach mal das
letzte level sein
ach so ok ich glaube ich muss loslassen
oder ich muss loslassen
ja ich muss loslassen wie kann ich mich
dann daran festhalten zum beispiel wie
wie geht das dass ich mich allerdings
unbedingt festhalten kann
ich probiere mal eine einmal shift
funktioniert auch nicht aber wir gehen
davon
ich probiere das jetzt einfach eben noch
einmal achso mit space funktioniert das
ach so wow so ist egal sagt nochmal
space so rutsche runter lappen
so halte ich fest halte ich fest
ok naja ich fliege einen weg hoch
mein gott was ist das noch mein gott oh
mein gott bitte nicht sterben da und
hier
ich hab mich festhalten müssen egal kein
bock mehr auf diesen mann so alle so das
beste level theo de kool ich lese schon
weil cod weil wir gerade in letzter zeit
ziemlich cod suchten und uns da wichtige
dinge jetzt aufgebaut haben richtige die
heißt es klassen für spezielle spielmodi
wie zum beispiel sprengkommando das
einer maske abnimmt und der andere eine
maschinenpistole damit er mit der
maschinenpistole in der nähe von bomben
platz bleibt aber das interessiert mich
jetzt gar nicht das wird er dann alles
auf den anzug blog
kommt schon wir schaffen das wir
schaffen das so wir sind in der
mülltonne
wir wollen wir das denn schaffen mein
gott